ladies and gentlemen Kevin Feige
it's very very cool what's exciting
particularly this year is we had a movie
called Captain America the Winter
Soldier guardians comes out this Friday
and I love the notion that you guys are
just as excited for a part two or part
three something that you've already seen
before the next adventure but you're
just as excited for something fresh and
something new with guardians and what
we're going to talk about today is 2015
we're doing a very similar thing we have
a movie called Avengers age of Ultron
that comes out I've heard of it and then
we have something new ant-man is finally
coming out you want to meet some people
involved in ant-man all right
the director of ant-man Peyton read the
first time visiting comic-con for both
of the ant-man I'm about to introduce
you to Paul Rudd and Michael Douglas
[Applause]
hank pym michael douglas period first
time the villain of our piece his name
is Darren cross we also call him the
yellowjacket in the film Corey Stoll
playing the daughter of hank pym hope
Van Dyne Evangeline Lilly what number
comic-con San Diego International
comic-con is this for you Peyton Reed
this is my 20th anniversary visit to
comic-con 1994 was the first summer I
went to comic-con it was the year Jack
Kirby passed away and I have been every
year since then I think - a couple of
years when I was shooting Paul Rudd
congratulations to you
[Applause]
you've never in you've never never been
to comic-con you've never sat up on this
stage before this is my first time here
[Applause]
they call that a comic-con virgin yeah
I'm a comic-con virgin how does it feel
- basically to come in to the Marvel
Universe as you know what will probably
be another like 10th point like you're
gonna be you're gonna be this guy for a
while like what does that feel like it's
a it's a mind bender it's so exciting
I'm so honored to be a part of it it's
really thrilling and um and I it's it's
kind of tough to wrap my brain around I
mean I've been doing this as a job for a
while but this is a whole other thing
and and I'm excited by the the
challenges I'm thrilled to be working
with such great people and looking
forward to see seeing how it all is what
is the experience been like for you to
come in as hank pym and what do you what
do you see what do you envision for the
character well you know I've always by
curiously looked at Marvel films from
afar with tremendous envy my entire
career has been
cup of doing kind of contemporary movies
without any special effects or anything
to so to have the joy and the love of
all these fantastic tools that so well
done and the ant-man stories is a
wonderful story and sort of be you're
surrounded with Peyton
Paul Evangeline Corey I'm just looking
forward to a real trip
tell us about tell us about hope and
dying and and and what your expense has
been like so far my experience so far
has been just evading the press that's
been generally been my experience on
ant-man I've been at Comic Con for two
days now answering questions about
ant-man but officially saying I'm not in
ant-man um so I'm very glad to announce
it I'm super happy to be here um I'm
obviously playing Hank pins daughter
hope him say that five times fast what
can you tell us about Darren cross Cory
um I really I mean I think that was
about it but well you know I am I was
Hank Pimm's mentee and the the genius
scientist as well and I am now I've
taken over the company and some very
judgmental people may think that that's
in an evil direction but I I think I'm
just taking it into the into the future
what can you keV can you tell us
anything about Darren cross uh I think
he did I think he did a marvelous job he
does at a certain point obtain some Pym
particles and and begins to give ant-man
a run for his money and again puts on a
suit that is called the Yellow Jacket
suit in the film and and causes havoc so
Darren cross actually will be yellow
jacket in the film